c'est c'est devenu de plus en plus
courant c'est le polyamour c'est un
numéro entier sur une pratique amoureuse
de plus en plus répandue aux états unis
le polyamour à ce que vous savez ce que
c'est que le polyamour oui regardez
dimanche soir m6 diffusait un nouveau
numéro du magazine enquête exclusive
au programme un reportage sur les états
unis et son rapport au sexe un pays où
tous les modes de vie sont possibles et
un sujet a particulièrement retenu
l'attention des téléspectateurs l'union
peu ordinaire que faure madame brook et
eve
un couple a trois que certains appellent
troubles et qui est désigné par
l'appellation polyamour une pratique gas
hub parfaitement ces trois américains et
qui semble leur convenir j'ai une
relation avec adam et j'ai aussi une
relation avec m deux ont une relation
ensemble et la majorité du temps on a
une relation à trois mais sur internet
certaines réactions se sont montrés
virulentes de la part d'internautes qui
ne partage visiblement pas la
philosophie de liberté sexuelle de
certains américains
ils ont un côté vraiment de générer
assez amerloques d'autres au contraire
semblé heureux que ce sujet soit abordé
à la télévision moi je suis plutôt pour
le polyamour mais ma femme beaucoup
moins alors le polyamour êtes vous pour
ou contre cette nouvelle tendance
alors le polyamour haut on vous en parle
et se soit on à isabelle brook est avec
nous voilà vous êtes réalisatrice et
vous êtes auteur bien sûr merci ou et
autres y sont des auteurs aussi un autre
auteur autrice hauteur c'est un mot qui
a été créée par les québécois ya
quelques dizaines d'années mais je suis
qui maîtrise très bien merci il ya
sylvain mimoun qui est avec nous merci
sylvain sexologue
merci d'être là alors le polyamour ou
contre cette nouvelle tendance
vous avez compris ainsi voilà c'est un
peu car kessel est caractérisée par la
police et d'une pour une personne d'être
simultanément impliqué dans plusieurs
relations amoureuses de manière
totalement assumée et honnête
alors bonne nouvelle delphine vous êtes
pour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
entre gens me et maxime je saurai pas
choisir et c'est pour ça j'ai pas envie
de choisir non je serais tu pas choisir
pour soit en l'avenir et tout ça vous et
tous peut-être arrivé d'être à un moment
où pensez être amoureux de deux
personnes en même temps et puis après on
est tiraillé on sait pas et tout et au
final on n'a qu'une seule vie on aime
ses deux parents on peut aimer plusieurs
enfants on peut aimer plusieurs hobby
pourquoi est-ce qu'en amour de la
relation amoureuse
on dit qu'il ya qu une personne en paix
mais c'est donc que tu n'as jamais été
amoureuse mon fils parce que parce que
tu l'a appris comme ça et non mais au
final tu peux aimer deux personnes bien
d'une manière du foncier car quand il ya
tout qui évolue il ya tout et on vous
embrasse roger
[Applaudissements]
mais je l'aimais bien sûr ça c'est moi
papa moi a lâché moi je veux pas su
mettre des barrières là où il y en a pas
ça va ça va nous taxer mais le demander
je suis entrain d'halluciner sur ce que
delphine est en train de rater son envol
mois de grosses comme et c'est très
grave ce que s'unit pour moi quand on
aime la grande personne l'amour à trois
ça n'existe pas ça a été inventé par jeu
pendant un jour mais je meurs
clairement été créée par dédain glamour
c'est une certaine on a vu une personne
et pour moi c'est des gens qui ont un
problème au cerveau parce que je viens
d'avoir le coeur pour personne puisque
l'autre est donc assez dégueulasse pour
la personne que tu aimes - quoi ça veut
dire que vous quand vous aimez une
personne vous n'aimez que cette personne
mince et envoyer ses s'appelle la vie
non mais ça non mais moi je suis un mois
je suis moi je suis un peu d'accord
voilà alors beaucoup alors sauf que
kelly ni c'est dégueulasse pour une
autre personne
ça se fait en toute intelligence et au
personnel compris c'est pas comme ça que
des gens qui disent non m'a sauvé en
turbo mieux des gens qui se mettent
d'ailleurs d'accéder qui filme ou des
couples qui vieillissent très mal et
tout ça au bout d'un moment vous mieux
et ça pour les avaler alain souhaite de
connaître la même chose
alors justement alors dans ce numéro de
enquête exclusive sur m6 on a pu
découvrir
adam brook et f c'est un couple a trois
kilos aux etats-unis dans cet extrait et
nous explique la différence entre la
polygamie et le polyamour regardez c'est
l'heure du réveil pour une famille qui
semble comme les autres
un détail près
dans le lit parental il y à trois
personnes les gens confondent le
polyamour et la polygamie la polygamie
c'est un homme qui a plusieurs femmes et
le polyamour c'est un mode de vie selon
lequel plusieurs personnes peuvent être
amoureuse les unes des autres
non mais je disais qu'en gros là
peut-être débat tout ça blabla mais en
vrai chacun fait ce qu'il veut et ce
qu'il veut non mais ce sera dur parce
que ça devient de plus en plus courant
alors docteur vous êtes sexologue
sylvain mimoun alors j'y vas est ce que
c'est normal ce qu'est ce que vient de
dire delphine wespiser qui dit qu'on
peut être amoureux de deux trois voire
quatre cinq six personnes ou voir en
soirée mais la normalité dans la
sexualité ça n'existe pas tout est
normal
si tenté que les personnes concernées le
vivent bien sont d'accord le vis bien le
vis bien d'accord non seulement ils sont
d'accord mais il le vivien s'ils ne
vivent pas bien s'il y en a une comme ne
sait pas qui l'a dit et qui est moqué
malheureuse et du coup ça fait souffrir
les autres c'est pas c'est pas le but de
l'amour d'accord alors donc il faut
voilà mais est-ce que c'est plus en plus
courant ça des lions qui franchement je
crois que c'est plus médiatique que réal
et à ces achats
c'est tout ça fait toujours un bon
papier ça chaque fois qu'il y à conques
on se met à parler de police pour ou de
mono amour ou de peu d'amour ou
d'absence de vie sexuelle etc
ça va intéresser des journalistes mais
est ce que ces journalistes vont faire
vivre la pause société ou est ce que
c'est la société qui va faire vivre les
journalistes et il vaut mieux que ce
soit de la deuxième solution
j'étais en cour d'assises
j'ai pris donc j'ai pris dans la gueule
alors regardé par un extrait où ils sont
tous les trois dans le même lit add on a
trouvé quelques avantages à faire ce
qu'on dit pas la cote a ici bien sûr
avec de fabre regarder le sexe à trois
c'est le meilleur truc du monde en tant
que mec je te la sûre à 100%
ce sont les meilleures relations
sexuelles de l'univers subissent archi
je veux que brooke et eve soient
satisfaites sexuellement du switch pour
moi en tant qu'homme
le fait de passer d'une partenaire à
l'autre ça diminue montant de
récupération physique
si je fais l'amour avec l'une des filles
et que je veux recommencer tout de suite
avec la même main parler mon coeur a du
mal mais si je passe à l'autre je suis
près tout ce qui se passe qu'est ce que
vous voulez là maintenant ça vous choque
ça ouais chaque très bon bah ouais mais
passer lewis est ce que je peux juste
répondre à delphine poli à moi c'est un
joli mois pour de la perversion alors
pour lui ça vient du latin
pauli polir et polaris a déjà eu des
sentiments pour plusieurs personnes
voilà et vivre avec deux j'allais me
coucher dans le lit avec deux pays avec
une personne ensuite l'autre d'avoir le
bébé dans l'île mais c'est dégueu céder
le père hubert la bouche le matin
alors alors là on à isabelle bourque et
aux tris et irradie le risque est alors
qu'ils te dis je qu'est ce que raconte
mamie alors vous vous trouvez secoué le
polyamour normal je veux dire la même
chose que ces chats il n'y a pas de
normalité du moment que les gens sont
heureux que ça leur convient à tous et à
fuel n'y a pas de l'enfant n'y a pas
d'injustice alors on doit ou voilà il
s'appelle juste pour savoir quelle est
la différence entre eux parce que là le
polyamour ils habitent tous ensemble ils
sont dans le même lit fouinant polyamour
aussi c'est comme l a dit ça veut dire
elle
voilà peut avoir un mec voilà truc elle
amoureuse aussi d'aller amoureuse de
deux mecs elle va voir aller un petit
peu chez soi mais qu'après l'été un
petit peu gestion de paix qu est ce que
ça c'est du polyamour alors déjà moi je
moi je dis pas polyamour moi je dis poli
amaury traduit de l'américain paulie
amaury et documents qui veut rien dire
il était en effet tout de suite parce
qu'on parle pas d'amour dont on parle de
quoi parle de relation plurielle avec la
sensuelle et éthiques
donc la possibilité ce n'est même pas de
la plage intéressant c'est la
possibilité de relations pluriel dans un
cadre consensuel éthique compagnie peut
y avoir de l'amour larmes nécessairement
d'accord d'accord beaucoup et c'est donc
ça nous fait dodo ça veut rien dire
d'autre que non monogamie éthique en
fait on sort de la monogamie et tout le
reste reste à inventer
alors la série à très cliché pour moi
c'est hyper léchée ce qu'on voit et moi
même je suis choqué de voir des gens qui
parlent de sexe mais devant un bébé
c'est vrai qu'on mélange pas les choses
la sexualité des adultes c'est la
sexualité des adultes les enfants et
pour moi ça n'a juste rien à voir avec
la polémique
c'est un cas particulier hyper
médiatique choquant si vous êtes pour ça
va faire plaisir à tous
je suis extrêmement choquée je vais leur
répondre sans colère et très calmement
de ce qu'on dit kelly et francesca
excusez moi mesdames
au nom de quoi vous êtes maintenant les
garantes les représentants de la morale
publique et de la sexualité librement ou
en espagne
si vous aviez une autorité morale et une
quelconque représentativité bas dans la
société française et vous vous êtes pour
déjà trouver les mots
[Applaudissements]
pour que l'amour à plusieurs l union
fait l'amour à plusieurs
oui je respecte tout ce que son pôle
amoureuse un pote qui est plus amoureux
il est extrêmement épanouie s'affranchit
de tout il a quasi un s'approcher de
toute culpabilité c'est une véritable
alternative aux couples traditionnels
quand même merci c'était juste pour dire
ça disons que ce qu'a dit que rien donné
sinon vous êtes le juge de 430 millions